attention j'ai fait une découverte de
fou dans ma vie une petite vidéo très
différent de tous les sketches de tous
les courts métrages voilà y'a pas une
équipe de 10 personnes avec des semaines
d'écriture et de réparation c'est une
vidéo toute simple pour vous parler d'un
truc qui m'a rendu fou je me baladais
comme ça tranquillement sur instagram et
il ya des gens qui peuvent se targuer
sur instagram savez ça s'est souvent des
selles fille je prends avec des gens en
dédicace dans la ruche pas quoi bref il
a ma gueule sur les trucs qu'on me tape
dessus ça paraît presque normal sauf que
je vois une vidéo d'une meuf qui m'a
tagué dessus un jour plus tard deux
jours plus tard il jours passent et je
vois de plus en plus de vidéos comme ça
2 jean king tag ce que je regrette sur
la vidéo ce n'est pas moi qui sont ces
gens qui me tape dessus je ne sais pas
un jour je décide de cliquer là qu'est
ce que je vois ma voix sur le corps de
quelqu'un d'autre alors oui j'ai choisi
allemand a levé 1 j'ai pas trop compris
pourquoi mais je comprends encore moins
ceux qui choisissent d'apprendre une
langue qui n'existe plus incroyable j'en
parle autour de moi à des potes [ __ ]
y'a des gens ils reprennent mes vidéos
mais ils refont les reflets les images
c'est rigolo etc
on me dit bah oui c'est tip top partait
du principe que je suis une personne
âgée donc j'avais entendu parler petit
coquin mais je j'ai repoussé le moment
où je devais créer un compte
tu es aux critiques tort j'en ai entendu
parler qu'est ce qui se passe dessus je
crée un compte
c'est parti entrons dans tik tok et
c'est là où le truc qui devenu fou c'est
que je vais sur tik tok je cherche si
rien est là qu est ce que je vois les
gens qui reprennent mes vidéos sûreté
toc
ça fait 26 millions de vues j'en avais
jamais entendu parler
c'est incroyable pour concept absolument
incroyable sur cette vidéo eh ben on va
découvrir toutes ces vidéos effectué
renoncé par l'espion isna pourtant sans
prévenir en scred
[Musique]
tu fais un stop non mais tu prévient
quand tu fais un snap c'est tout tu fais
pas ça en scred c'est génial ils
connaissent mieux le sketch que moi j'ai
fait qu'une seule fois de la saison que
ça a été répétée et tout ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir et surtout de voir
des gens surtout des filles avec ma voix
c'est très perturbant
ça mérite un petit like anglais pour la
conjugaison du verbe haut mais c'est la
même chose
bah c'est à yann c'est génial c'est noir
ou milliard sous le cg mis une petite
bouille et à une petite couilles alors
ça énorme une fille avec ma voix qui dit
une petite couilles j'adore on se remet
une fois une petite couilles selick et
on est d'accord qu'on est sûr en 1 95 %
de filles peut-être que les mecs ils
font des vidéos d'autres voix la voix
c'est que les filles qui sont autorisés
à refaire mais mes vidéos je ne sais pas
jamais tu un petit peu particulier un
métier qui n'existait pas il ya quelques
années je suis auteur comédien
réalisateur monteur producteur de vidéos
sur internet youtube heures c'est ça
franchement je suis très flatté chez il
ya des gens qui regardent les vidéos et
melilla je vois juste les commentaires
de tous comme ça et de voir que les gens
les connaissent par coeur son fait
extrêmement plaisir merci à tous tous
ces gens là qui refonde et où est la
faille et j'aime bien la petite surprise
deux je sais pas quel sketch ils vont
reprendre
surprise oui donc non il ya un truc qui
m'insupporte quand apprend une langue
c'est les mecs qui se [ __ ] de ta
gueule parce que tu t'es un peu trompé
en parlant de la dila camille père
expressif je trouve ça fou astro leur cv
vous mettez des oursins dans votre slip
ya pas de blague n'y a pas de moi c'est
génial franchement monsieur comédie
laïque et comme jamais mon médecin il un
peu chelou
il parle en baragouinant génial donc ça
c'est carrément une vidéo de norman
écrit quand même acheté avec comédie
france une mort cyprien médecin youtube
cette personne n'a jamais regardé cette
vidéo puisque c'est normal je n'ai pas
fait de vidéo sur les médecins pour
joaillier nouveaux trucs qui sortent par
exemple les écouteurs sans fil 1,80
balle merci apple je pratique ma
grand-mère est donc totalement fou mais
pas mal les filles sont jumelles du coes
dijon va faire à deux la voix comme ça
c'est tout aussi clair autant se
redonner différents rôles mais là ils se
disent non mais attends on le fait en
même temps tu fais toi ou je fais moi le
quand il parle cyprien est bon je fais
toutes les deux malin cherche mes
écouteurs il était là où c'est le blanc
c'est bon je m'en suis occupé mais c'est
quoi comment faire une grand-mère ces
îles et plaidera les traces du matelas
et un peu de maquillage mais je devrais
faire ça c'est bon chez une grand mère
ont pas je pense que je suis une grand
mère maintenant les gens ne feront pas
la différence
j'ai duper les plus grands je suis un
génie déguisement le prof qui a perdu
les devoirs mais qu'il faut pas le dire
ce devoir d'y adia trois mois là c'était
plutôt pas c'est bien je crois que oui
tout le monde a besoin tout le monde a
vraiment eu 20 la ranger ma copine hagen
vraiment on peut même s'applaudir je
pense pas mal
l'effort d'avoir mis une classe et
cetera d'avoir réparti les rôles y
ajoute la synchro sur la fin qui est à
l'essai à désirer mais gros effort en
perspective voilà je suis un prof de tik
tok
j'évalue aux tic toc pas mal non enfin
ils soient payés pour sa part
l'éducation nationale comprend pas
comment on a pu appeler des fruits de
mer des fruits de mer s'il ya bien un
truc qui ressemble pas influencer ça au
petit emoji crevettes un mec qui s'est
dit dirait un peu espoir c'est vrai
lâche objet de mettre une bonne note
c'est un 9 sur 10 facile parce qu'il ya
l'apparition de lesmo j ai du montage on
n'est pas loin du skill berlin je vous
vois tous regardé avec beaucoup d'envié
ma cop crustacés fait avec lucas on a
lancé la boutique bigorneaux et
coquillages et vous pouvez commander les
produits et tous les bénéfices iront à
l'association cékedubonheur qui va aider
et soutenir les enfants dans les
hôpitaux plus à payer des t-shirts et
tout ça si vous vous en sentez vraiment
propre oui bien sûr vérifions ça
regardez les bactéries mais je me suis
bon c'est l'évidence même pas avec
colgate total dans la ville
c'est ce que j'aime faire chier dans la
boue en plus c'est pour mon objet dans
stahl et oncle il est prof du combat
bravo là il ya carrément le petit
panneau dans la vie beaucoup de talent
la perruque et au début j'ai cru que
c'était une femme
on est sur un degré de réalisme c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait les instagram ce
qu'ils disent attention moi c'est ce que
j'aime faire chier dans la rue en un an
+ époux faisaient dans stahl et on cuit
l'épreuve du coup c'est génial que plein
de genres dix sept répliques et ton qu
il est propre donne à tous d'ailleurs
petite exclusivité la prochaine vidéo ce
sera les plus beaux de versus la vie le
nouvel opus vous gardez pour vous oui
j'ai plus ou moins d'abonnés smash elle
je demande de garder pour vous et c'est
un pays hypocrite je le reconnais on va
faire un jeu je vais essayer de deviner
la vidéo juste avec la miniature je
pense que ça avec le trou créé à droite
et le béret je dirais que c'est les
langues étrangères fut dit un ou une
canapé d'autant qu'au gaz et des genres
objets superbe exécution mais je les
noirs un truc là votre futur beurre
préféré perso squeeze et annick scène et
je suis pas dedans
les gens disent quoi dans les
commentaires ça aura un mix m je trouve
qu'il ya pas beaucoup mon prénom dans un
truc où c'est ma vive et où quand même
c'est pas grave je ne fais pas ça pour
la gloire
je fais ça pour la beauté de la balle au
bond et supporter les choses c'est la
vie est très dure neuf mois c'est
douloureux ça laisse des vergetures et
vomir c'est trop bien à tous quoi on
fait tous les personnages poussait
vraiment fort d'ailleurs je les fais
récemment mon contrat je fais un voeu
c'est un exercice que j'aime beaucoup du
coup j'aime bien le voir si chez les
autres tu te voir la voix d'alison
wheeler qui va si bien j'adore
maintenant je reste appuyé sur ton
visage lisse sur la droite cherche trop
trop bien 10 sur 10
tout le monde sait à hollywood que c'est
dur de tout avec des chiens c'est
infernal et ben voilà on refait le
sketch on prend carrément les
accessoires tous les différends figurant
notamment le chien super impossible
s'énerver avec de l'hélium l'année c'est
pas bientôt fini
ces cas par cas quoi c'est d'apporter
parfois de quoi faire je sais même pas
d'où vient cet extrait aucune idée
ok personnages et alzheimer tout va bien
propriété de l'intégrale sont vraiment
très très très important bonjour je suis
un homme lambda cadres en entreprise
c'est très bizarre d'avoir ma voix sur
quelqu'un qui visiblement n'est pas un
homme lambda
d'ailleurs je pense qu'on a le même
physique n'est ce pas regarder on est
pareil il ya quelques jours j'étais
invitée au mariage de ma cousine le
week-end prochain je l ai un mariage or
c'est chiant les gens passent derrière
tranquille on au ce trop stylé c'est
marrant parce que je pensais pas que les
gens allaient reprendre cette vidéo sur
le mariage de ma cousine n'est ce pas
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya des tic toc
sur tout et n'importe quoi en fait de
mes vidéos des extraits parfois qui n'a
aucun sens d'ailleurs peut-être que
cette vidéo sera dans un tick tock y
aura peut-être un tip top de gens qui
disent ces phrases la tic toc ception
c'est quoi à saint sozy j'ai trouvé un
sosie
on est quand même un petit truc si je
puis me permettre d'en découvre aussi
des choses identiques toc c'est quand
même intéressant pour un peu cyprien
rentrer à la maison sort rentrer sort
contre je redécouvre meskhètes j'avais
oublié que ça se terminer comme ça ça va
roi clovis premier né en 466 moi ce que
je peux poser une question simple et
bien sûr qui s'emballe totalement les
couilles ici ces personnes je fais très
très bien moi qui fais un prof
d'histoire si je puis me permettre
louvier se promener c'est un 10 sur 10
alors il faut que je vous dise un truc
franchement ça me fait trop plaisir de
voir je sais pas tu sais les sketchs
voilà c'est d'être vidéo que je fais
depuis si longtemps j'ai oublié
carrément ce qu'il y avait dedans et de
voir qu'en fait il ya des gens qui les
reproduisent comme ça avec et si bien eh
ben voilà
bravo à vous c'est génial alors moi
j'aimerais faire un truc ce tournoi la
critique facile les gens se moquent
est-ce que c'est facile de faire un tick
tock je me plains pas avec mon corps
c'est juste que le mec qui a un immeuble
qui on essaie de faire ça mais perdu les
plans ok donc là je découvre toutes les
vidéos qui utilisent le même extrait ok
je découvre tik tok on est en 2018 je
suis une personne âgée vous appuyez là
dessus bonjour tu imagines si je
s'appuyer plaint pas ok on va la faire
au ralenti on peut le faire
excusez moi c'est mon premier tictoc
deux mois sur moi ok c'est une nouveauté
on n'a jamais vu çà tik tok ception je
me plains pas ok on a ça là je change de
tenue comme ça vous avez aussi le making
of de comment faire
le patronat tout ceci en
on découvre me plains pas avec mon corps
c'est juste que le mec qui a imaginé mon
corps avait perdu les plans il est parti
en impro je m'appelle round je suis le
créateur du corps de cyprien pour faire
simple chef et non pour tout quoi assez
nul quand les gens sont meilleurs que
moi j'ai honte
mon premier tic toc j'ai honte car vous
êtes meilleure attaque cyprien hashtag
humour pas si douée que ça très bon
acheter avec publiés j'ai honte de ce
tic toc qui est 100 fois moins bon que
ce que font les autres je suis tellement
pas 5 rochus [ __ ] je suis nul mais
vous êtes très bon merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo un petit peu spécial il
n'est pas un sketch un court métrage ou
ce genre de choses mais ça m'a fait très
plaisir de partager ce moment avec vous
et petite surprise pour vous là c'est
bientôt noël vous pouvez rejoindre mon
petit truc ici et moi je vais mettre
plein de d'extraits de mes vidéos là qui
sont pas encore dessus vous puissiez les
refaire voilà ça c'est fait vous éclater
là dessus y'a pas de soucis merci pour
tous ces petits cadeaux vous m'avez fait
voilà en utilisant des extraits même si
certains les ont
bref encore un peu de marge de
progression mais vous êtes quand même
meilleur que moi merci beaucoup je vous
dis à très vite sur internet
abonnez vous
[Musique]